welcome back episode 6 out a program in
C++ beginner series last time we did
project build a little calculator as you
can see there's a lot of repeating code
so this is a perfect time to introduce
functions one of the main points of
functions is to be able to take areas of
your code where you replicate things and
only do it once following a rule called
dry so functions and what does dry mean
it's an acronym for do not repeat
yourself I guess it would be don't so
that's what yourself so that's what dry
stands for it's a common vernacular here
among programmers if you're typing the
same thing over and over kind of like I
guess these sections right here you see
it here see it here so we could we could
just have a function that handles these
replicating lines of code so to make a
function well if you're doing it all in
one file you first want to have up at
the top well you can declare your whole
function up here and remember this nth
main is a function too it's just the
entry point so when you're compiling and
running your program it always looks for
that if you want to make your own
function first you put in the return
type if it has no return type its void
and then the name of your function will
call it get entries for now and
and then in parentheses and these are
the variables you pass in so if you end
it here it is just a what do they call
it forward declare I believe a forward
declaration of it so that your program
recognizes it so if you do it this way
you have to once again I don't know how
open that then take control see you got
to go below your main type it again
except this time instead of the
semicolon you own two brackets and this
is where you define what it actually
does with just more code and if it has a
return type you need a return or
whatever it is again this since this is
voice not a return or anything but we
want to just take this section here and
put it in here and that way we can just
call and get entries and at this section
of the code anytime were that way we're
not repeating that same four lines it's
gonna save us some lines of code however
this divided one is a little different
so it's not necessarily where you know
not a full repeat right there but you
know what we could do is we could modify
this a little bit and I suppose we do
that we'll do get entries and we'll do
this check again except we'll just put
this here it's just gonna prompt for the
first number again to so so we'll get
rid of this but still gonna do this
check on the second number and replicate
it's just gonna prompt for both now so
that sort of cuts it down a little bit
but this function does not know about
first number and second number because
these are declared within the scope of
this main and then within this while
loop so these would have to be there's
two different ways I can think of off
top my head here to do this you could
either make these global which means you
put them up here
and that way everything in the file
knows about them but you typically don't
want to do Global's I mean you can it's
not gonna hurt anything in this small
case but if we want to kind of keep it
how it was I can show you a little more
about functions so we can say that this
get entries will take in some variables
to change and now try to go over this
quickly and also accurately but there's
kind of a lot to passing in variables so
first of all you they need a type and a
name we'll just make it first and then a
float second but when they're just like
this in this plane way it passes them as
a copy so you wouldn't be actually
modifying this number that you're
passing in you'd be modifying the copy
or working with the copy so what you
need to do instead is pass by reference
and you do that with an ampersand in
between them so this passes by reference
which means it's a reference to the
variable it is the actual variable that
you're passing in when you're working on
it in that way the changes we make to it
are essentially saved when we continue
down in our program
no often when things are a reference
you'll see that the user will have
constant in front of it which means you
cannot change these and that's an
efficient way to pass in variables
because you're passing a reference to it
rather than making a copy so uses less
memory and make sure it doesn't get
edited but in our case we do want to
edit them because we're doing a cien to
change them and as you notice the name
is changed but it is referencing the
same variable and we just have to be
sure to actually pass those in here
so this here is calling the function so
we'll just go ahead and do that and now
our program should working exactly as
before except now we're doing it
oops now we're doing it with a function
rather than typing the same code over
and over so I'll go ahead and compile
this wait a three plus plus main dot CPP
and we will run it and we should get the
same thing as last time but now when we
do divide Waner the second number is
zero it's gonna start from the first
number because it just starts over and
runs this again so that is a very basic
version of a function as we go forward
I'll continue making functions and
you'll see some other things you can do
with them and one of the points of
passing by reference is when you need to
return multiple things you'll see this
often like if we were just returning or
getting one number we could just return
a float and in here we could have it get
the float and return it and that would
kind of be a different story
but since we need two of them and we can
only return one thing that's why I'm
doing it by reference now it's important
to note that there are other ways to
return multiple numbers such as you
could put them in an array or in a
vector by doing an include vector you
can use vectors and as we go forward
we'll get more advanced I hope you
enjoyed this quick episode on functions
and thanks for sticking with it good on
you and I'll see you in the next episode
keep code